so today topic is have to use the
seventh and eighth rank I prepared one
game who played which played between ik
and the Georgian they are both world
champions and first of all was night a
3d 5d for Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight c3 c5
who knows the name of opening tell me
touch the fence and he takes d5 Knight
takes d5 and the most popular is if for
my text III be take C 3 C takes D force
it takes d4 Bishop before which was
tested in their match illusion Ava and
instead went for the last known type of
position at that time between ik decided
to play III in this position so knight
c6 Bishop c4 to devolve the pizzas right
C takes D form what will you do yeah
first of all of this it takes before
black open C file right because the main
idea for white in the future to play if
Bishop e7 take the pawn on c5 Bishop
takes d5 and black was the tempo
so between ik decided take it takes d4
Bishop is 7 and what white can play him
castle of course and what black should
play on same day well now what is the
best move for right here what is the
main idea of more Queen even
okay but why not the roof Yvonne was the
same idea and about the roof because of
the Queen e1 yoke on the pond has no job
right so it's a typical strategy idea in
the middle of the game to play rook e1
attack the put the spell on if I may be
to play Knight e5 in the future and
positionable isolated pawns always
belong to between x5 but it's thanks to
his efforts to revoke all opportunities
that there are present in such positions
chess players have lost their almost
mystical and they are off playing with
isolated pawns in the center this fear
had been pervasive since Dainius and
impressive victories over to quor'toth
and the powerful logical arguments the
first volley champion put forth against
creating unnecessary weaknesses but
Winnick was the first to prove
constantly the active pins play was
pressure in the center were often more
than compensates for a slight defect of
the pawn structure it's interesting to
play Knight c3 B takes c3 b6 Bishop d3
Bishop d7 h4
what will you do here what is the main
idea of who h4 fight
okay what else so to push hy maybe in
the future also maybe to play Knight g5
right because GF is quite strong so
Bishop takes h4 night take stage for
twin takes and the rookie fede no idea
to put the rook on the H file yes but a
rookie free and the wreckage free is
better than the rook h1 and White has
strong attack on the H file and h7 Puna
REO is weak so it's a typical idea how
to sacrifice the phone on H file
the to use open page file
also Asics the best attempter is
probably this and it's okay so in the
game was more basics dubious move so
what do I should play here ok we need to
develop our queen but what is the best
quality ok it's interesting idea but in
this position correct move Knight takes
d5 it takes d5 what will you do here
Bishop d3 go back and then Queen C to
attack the pond on h7 maybe I'll open
and will not see that we want to eat
this paella we should be fine we should
be fine that's correct move to attack
this night with the temple and despite
the symmetrical pawn structure black as
Nava doomed to a passive defense
weaknesses on the C file and a slight
disk or donation of the black pieces
give white and is the game in which you
can develop his initiative so yeah
correct move was for black Bishop d7
Queen a for Queen d6 and offered much
better chances first successful defense
also interest in rook c8 Bishop a4 a6
and it's interesting position for black
but in this position na do-kyun decided
to play Bishop d7 which is London
why who can explain first of all we
played pistols with the idea to develop
Bishop to be sounds crown right okay
what else I don't like your MOOC in situ
because if rook c8 it will be dangerous
in a huge freaking it's better to put
the rook on c1 first of all and then if
you need you can put your queen on c2 so
if I supposed to use this open file with
zero but the blog will have two bishops
after Bishop takes it says Bishop takes
c6 what is the best color for Queen in
this position now right now in this
position yes Queenie for why not crenate
for because knight on c6 is V so this
should be five and clean only for Adam
this night what black should play him
okay efforts the 8th Bishop f4 what
black can play here
and black has problems with his neck
small ethics right now okay maybe I
should take bishop takes c6 Bishop takes
c6 and Queen takes c6 of t6 when the
pond like this
so it's difficult position for black so
what does the main idea for you if you
open an attic your peace strategy area
to defend what else
and now idea counterattack what else
yes maybe trade the pieces what else to
move us that piece right of course might
be it said the retreat but what we can
play here so what is the best move for
white in this position make a natural
move here make a natural move develop
your pieces we should have four yes to
the value B Bishop and was idea Bishop
takes b8 and Bishop takes d7 so black
should take the bishop on b5 and
exchange the bishops between takes B
five a six what do I should play go back
yeah
and what is the main idea of this move
yes
keeping the knight on b8 in its misery
okay Bishop d6 in order to relieve
pressure yes yes
it's rook e8 and 97 or 96 maybe better
but I have a double attack know if rook
e8 96 are okay - you won
I can take your Akane eight I cut the
old queen from a four-year diagonal so
98 I can play 96 now you cannot play
rook e1 because I will take Europe do
you understand that so you should
exchange and okay maybe King takes the
fate so not good
yes sir okay she wants so what is the
main idea for you in this position after
the case you want stop the night like
cannot develop 96 yes what else to put
the rock on the open sea file strategy
idea
okay okay seven what is the main idea of
the small block okay maybe so yeah to
prevent the rooks is seven in the future
and develop the rook Queen c2 your idea
but in this time so what is the main
idea of this more why in this moment
Queen c2 is good
okay may be possible to play in the
future Quincy it but it's not dangerous
right now because 97 what house if my f
ing six if you have open fire the main
idea also for you to double pieces on
the open file in this position the rook
only one is good so that's why you
double your Luke and queen on c5 this
idea to stop rook c7 to exchange the
rooks so what if Knight d7 what white
will play
yes Quincy silkscreen takes c6 rook
takes c6 and and game does not promise
any speed moments
so after ninety seven blacks position
looks reasonable but unfortunately for
him all the weaknesses remain permanent
so black played the rook is seven in
this position what white should play why
I don't want to trade the rooks
yes
you all right Quintus son so the main
idea for you if you have open file to
use the sounds or a trunk and your rukon
c7 is really strong but after this
useful exchange the divided rook
penetrates the black ranks and I look
him right Lee estimated that this rule
alone was not able to cause serious
damage and f6 he played what is the main
idea of the small okay to stop a 95 and
95
with Lydia in the future to play rook of
7 yes ok 8 for example rook b7 what
black will play him same ideas for white
to put the rock on LC pile and to tag
the first rank because skin is weak and
f king of 1 now you can push b5 then you
get this C file the file is good for you
so after route b7 wide lost control on C
file well that's why it's not good for
white so what why should play instead
rhombus and hyung
what does the main idea of MOOC in the
phone yes and tries and akin to them in
the endgame
what black should play here so again why
did he play abstract rock up stab and we
wanted to play to exchange the rooks
Roxie eight again Ruka fade draw as good
result for black so white right when all
why should play here every will exchange
the rooks but we lost our advantage
we have advantage because we have rookin
see file and you can use seventh rank or
its rank and after Luke takes a fate a
verrucas battened and black through
so we should go back but to whisk wah
proxy free so going back in the bashes
the pants again at the right moment and
the pawn cemeteries shouldn't fool
anyone
Black is not able to restore the
coordination of the pieces in case below
for example 97 what will we do
again the Roxy 7 Roxy 7 and again to use
the sounds rank night b8 and Black was
the tempo
so same will be after kin f7 so so in
this position black played G PI a smart
idea pushing his palm on the Kin site
that you can reduce the importance of
the ceramic veg will sooner or later be
dominated by his openness Luke also was
the idea to stop h4 medium so what do I
should play here g4
but how many a movie should spend to
pull the night on the fire even g2e free
than a file so four moves and then what
I think I can try to play King g7 then
King g6 and h5 this idea to to open each
file
I'm not sure about the small geophone
while I bet more actually you have not
big choice what a friend can ID to a
mighty one on my g1 no g1 okay yes 91 91
the idea may be nicely to night before
or 92 93 95 that's why I'm in this
position
Doug decided to push h5 phone yes but
also if h6 what a white can play
welcome so finite c2 king of 793
kinesics so why not g 4q g for me so
while it has strong [ __ ] on the five
and put on each successive you call so
yes
okay so H five now H for and what is the
main idea of the small
yes for the new witnesses on the Kin
side and now blacks defensive lines
breaking apart his best pieces cannot
operate effectively all over the board
so after g4 we will play in visual
which move night-night different night
afore and black will have to weak bones
h5 and d5 so black played Knight d7 what
is the best move for white yes and in
full control row consists on look at
seven
yes night if it is the same idea to play
night before and that both ones
yes that's why it may be after night DVD
I can push a file but question is what
black should play after night c2 so
maybe I have tonight see to black and
play Knight of fate whose area to
exchange the rooks and rook takes up
some context of so Knight e3 we have
move King e6 white played in this
position I have free this area to attack
the pawn on g5 LG takes - fall you can
take 90s edge fold and use a 5 gram g4
now what
91 with Libya 93 and I perform and take
these both bones b5 + h5 f5 so why did
we play nighty 193 f4 so white cannot
play night afore but a-poppin is weak
right now right to move in this position
okay let's calculate night except for
who takes for rook takes d7 that rook
takes if I deform not good if Knight e5
Knight takes e5 we lost night okay yes
we have a looksie a check
maybe I look afraid Luka fate kim taek's
of faith he takes d5 kini 7 can be when
in position for black so this bond is
weak but maybe blog will push the free
energy future f3 f3 yes it's correct
G take G takes a5 a4 Tina fate
Roxy sex Kimi 7 king of to Luka 5 be
free so there's no need to hurry
kindiy 8 Kinney to not be it so if rook
takes b6 what black and play kin c7 was
the real knight c6 gives black country
chances so not good
Oh white can play rugby Phi about 96 the
check the pawn on d4 and white cannot
protect it if Rukh a5 Knight takes d4
Knight xb3 ok it's good idea c5 and e5
really week's class so you will see how
why do you sit in the game yeah ROG 6
wide used open C file also with the idea
to use another open G file so it's also
one of strategy idea if you have open
file and Sochi file was like springboard
for the rook and you can use now g6g
files crown so keen c7
and what did you say and not with [ __ ]
on the fifth sixth or seventh rank which
is protected by a ball on the open file
and which cannot be attacked by a now
open spoon as usual the fifth squares
and the outputs grass in the center or
for the night
95 can use right if for example you have
outputs the scroll on AG file you can
use it with your hook and double your
looks okay
so 95 and making sure this counterpart
will not participate in the game so
might be eight but if my d7 what will
you play rock g7 96 a ruby g7 but it was
a little better for white to play room
g5 to exchange the rooks and wininet bit
quicker because rook g5 h TG Falcon d6
ji-sook skinny 7 g7 yeah
so room g7 can see it also the main idea
to cut the keen on the seventh rank to
use the sounds ranked 96 broke up 697
right can be 8 Knight takes d5 at most a
room d6
a ruby g5 this idea to protect the night
25 and detect the h-pipe on night before
night eggs before it takes before in the
end tonight's which such different
histories both disappear together but it
gives black no satisfaction
since the rook and game is absolutely
lost rook takes stage 5 a frog Dafoe it
was interesting wolf of the crocodile
King c7 h5 and weak bones are still
around so it's been in production for
white so I took here Brooke c6 a ruby
file can see seven rook takes before
lukkage silks room b5 rook takes h4
kindy free and urea kina for so black
designed and a low hand said one time
that of the 14th games I played in this
tournament on the ones that I feel that
my open and outplayed me so it was gain
was between neck in round 7 and no
future comments I needed